well let's go to the air now we know
that international travel took a major
hit these past couple of years due to
the pandemic but now it's at the top of
the list as more destinations are
opening to visitors bianca holman spoke
with travel expert peter greenberg who
says now's the time to start making your
summer plans tell us more bianca i want
to get to the air i want to jump on a
boat what can we do
yes we want to do all of that sherry
well if you may think that summer is far
off but it really is it's right around
the corner so if you plan on going on a
family vacation the time to start
booking is right now especially if you
plan on flying out of harry reid
international airport so a big trend
that we're seeing this year is that
cruising cruising is back and is up
again there are 300 ships that are
hitting the seas and many are brand new
one of the 24 new ships that will set
sail in 2024 sold out in 30 minutes and
there's a big demand covet has required
the ships to make some changes
they had already had to comply with
about 75 different changes in design
physical structure meals short
excursions of course vaccinations
they're really getting their act
together in the cruise industry they've
changed all their ventilation systems
their contact tracing their medical
facilities and so people can actually
cruise with confidence
also keep in mind covet tests are
required for lots of international
travel and a negative covet test to
return back here to the states mass
still required on planes and in the
airport now another big trend is going
to be national parks a lot of people may
not want to fly but they want to visit
someplace in their state that has a
national park a lot of those parks will
require reservations so it's going to be
large crowds again plan in advance and
start booking those things now and we've
got more information on flights coming
up in the next half hour bianca holman
live local now